so bill you seem to know a lot of
screenwriters and I'm wondering if the
screenwriters that you've come in
contact with of the ones who have sold
scripts are they any better than the
ones who've never sold scripts ooh
that's a really interesting question
because I here's what I think I think
the ones that haven't sold scripts they
there's some lesson they haven't learned
yet and the ones that have sold scripts
have learned some of those lessons and
although here's theirs this is it
impossible for me to answer question
because here's the thing someplace sorry
someplace there's a screenwriter that
hasn't sold a script that has figured
out all the answers now and what they're
waiting for is the luck element but did
I talk about traveling scripts last time
okay I believe that if you have a great
script nothing stands in its way and
here's why the script that I sold it but
I tell this story went oh I don't know
if I should tell this story on camera
but anyway telling it anyway here's the
thing I'm so I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna tell a slightly fictionalized
version okay another thing that happened
so the slightly fictionalized version so
no names names will not be named is I
had a script that I wrote and gave to a
friend of mine who to read and give me
notes instead of reading it he left it
on his coffee table where his roommate
who's in a GarageBand read the script
his roommate in the GarageBand took it
to his garage band rehearsal and that
script passed around the band then that
script passed around to the next band
and the next band and the next band and
traveled through the business of bands
traveled to every unsigned garage band
in Los Angeles until finally it came to
somebody who had a connection to a film
producer
and I get a call from this person I
don't know who says I read your script I
have a meeting with his film producer
can I pitch it to him and I said
absolutely but that was a script that
didn't go through any normal channels if
you have that script that's that good
then somebody reads it and goes this is
a good script and in this business
everything is about trying to get to I
don't know to do favors to earn favors
so a a guy who is that unpaid intern
read your script and goes this is now my
chance to become the paid script reader
so they turn it over to the boss and say
I found the script it's it's wonderful
and hopefully because they found the
great script they get promoted and so
that's how this business works is
everyone's trying to find the great
script so if you have the great script
and you give it to the wrong person it
will still sell one of my one of my
script deals that happen happen because
the temp receptionist for a production
company I cold called
I pitched my script and he goes well it
sounds like a lot of the posters around
here but I'm the temp receptionist I
can't do for you and I said can I
send you my you know when when is your
temp time up because I'm here for
another you know another week and a half
and I said can I send you the script can
you read it goes I can't do anything for
you
said that's fine can I send you the
script and so I sent him the script he
read it and went this is a great script
and so he then pitched it to the head of
development and the head of development
read the script
probably reluctantly and said this is a
great script so I sold that script to
the company based on the temper ception
as' the temper ception this became the
full-time receptionist I mean you know
his he got promoted the head of
development ended up eventually becoming
a head of production and all these
things happen because this guy who had
no chance to do anything for me read my
script but that's the way the business
kind of works is you get your script out
there so the difference between that
unsold writer and that sole writer or
writer that's made money is it's not as
much access as it is the material so
that sold writer has often learned some
lesson what ever that lesson is that the
unsold writer hasn't that that isn't
always true because there's
unsold writers are right there on the
edge and it's just about to happen and
it will happen but there are other
writers that aren't there yet so one of
the things I always say is read your
five favorite screenplays and read yours
if one of these is not like the other
you aren't ready yet
if you read your five favorite
screenplays and then read yours and you
go my script is on the same level as
these then you're probably ready but a
lot of people think they're ready in the
art that goes back to self honesty it
does it does but I mean there's so
there's so many different the thing
about a screenplay is it's a million
different working parts and getting them
all to line up is like often a miracle
you know even there even for a
professional writer okay now I'm gonna
tell the story without the name
I met a famous professional writer who
at the time was the number one
screenwriter in the world and a
screening of one of his movies and
because I'm I wasn't want to be screamed
at it at the time oops I'm sorry because
I wasn't want to be screenwriter at the
time I knew what he looked like so I
went up to him and talked to him and
there had been a script of his that have
been in the trades that because he was
famous the whole deal was that was gonna
be his next big script and the studios
were gonna pay a lot of money for it and
then nothing happened I said so whatever
happened to that script he goes well
they can't all be winners I said wow
that's awesome that here's a guy that
probably could have sold his laundry
list and wrote the script that didn't
work and so he went this script didn't
work I could probably sell it but it's
never gonna be a good movie so I'm
putting it aside on that shelf until he
figures out how to make it work and so
even somebody that's a professional can
write a script that doesn't work and the
new writer often doesn't realize that
the script doesn't work in the first
place there because there's so many
different working parts there could be a
part that's not working the the main
thing often with new writers is they
they either go to soulless commercial
crap or way too personal that has no
commercial aspects and it's like finding
that middle ground is often the tough
thing to do and that ends up being the
thing that I think is the the average
writer probably has trouble finding that
middle ground the other thing is in and
this is like more recent thing is
probably writers voice
which is a writer needs to write so
distinctively that when I read their
script I go I know who wrote this and
that's one of those things that takes
time to develop to figure out who the
hell you are as a person as a writer and
figure out how to get that on the page
and that again that's one of those
that's one of those little end lessons
that's like you can get everything right
and not have that and that might be the
thing that could get you reads that can
get you a lot of things without having
that voice the voice is often the thing
that takes the good script and turns it
into the great script because now you're
giving us a point of view you're giving
us a sort of a look into a world that
nobody else can give that look into that
is the worst sentence ever but I get it
is what you're saying so tell me again
that that phrase again which should be a
bumper sticker by the way you talked
about bumper stickers yeah which praises
Hollywood is a place that you provide
favors to get things yeah yeah yeah
basically I don't I don't even know what
I said because I said it off the top of
my head it's everyone is going to try to
find a favor to give someone so they can
later on collect a favor
and so it's all it's like a favor
business so I'm gonna do this favor for
you and then later on I'm going to ask
you for a favor but when I ask you for
that favor I better be careful that this
is the one favor I want to ask because
you can do things where again some of my
- career mistakes have been asking for
stupid favors when I could have asked
for a better favor and you don't realize
you know sometimes that you're at that
point where you can ask for a better
favor and new writers here's new writers
can make friends with established
writers and you don't want to ask the
favor too soon because if you ask the
favor too soon then you're the person
that's just climbing and we all see you
as the social climber but if you let it
go out along for a while be the friend
for a while then eventually you can get
to the point where and if you're clever
clever the clever word if you're clever
instead of saying
can I would like you to introduce me to
your agent
the clever writer says could you read my
script and tell me what's wrong with it
and what you hope is they read your
script they go
this is an awesome script I'm gonna hand
this to my agent because that's a favor
I'm doing for my agent who will then do
a favor for me later on and send out
that's that pet script of mind that my
agent doesn't want to send out because
it's not commercial no one's gonna buy
this
maybe my agent will send it out then
clever versus intelligent
oh it's intelligent but you know it's
like you're still you're you're being
intelligent but at the same time you're
looking at things and going
this is Machiavellian yeah yeah there's
the clever thing involved in there but
but basically what you want to do is you
want to you don't want to waste your
favor on something stupid because I've
wasted favors on stupid things a million
times my career is a mess because I'm
stupid no seriously you look back at
things ago man if I just done this
instead of this I would be better off
now one of the I don't know if I talked
about it last time but I producer wanted
me to adapt Angels & Demons the Dan
Brown devil I turned it down because I
hated the book that was before it was
Ron Howard and and Tom Hanks but had I
said yes just because look I'll get paid
I'll you know I'll adapt this book for
money instead I went I hate this book I
don't want to I don't want to do it but
if I would just would have adapted it
for money I would probably have well I
don't know writers guild rules changed
recently for screenplay credits but for
adapted stuff but at that point in time
I probably would have had a screenplay
credit on a Ron Howard movie but you
know you look back and stuff like that
you know I made a mistake there and you
know that's you can look back on
anything in your life and go that was a
stupid thing to do I'm not sure this is
part of the interview
you